ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวัน
นี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันอังคารค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 31
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤษภาคมปีพตอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีคศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อ
วานนี้วันจันทร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 30 เดือนเดือน
มีสภาคมปีพตตปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีคศปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วันพุธ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
1  36 ไม่ตาม
ฟ้าจะพูด 32 ไม่กี่นะคะๆ
เดือนอะไรคะ
มกราคม
มิถุนายน
เดือน
มิถุนายนปีพตอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะค่ะแต่
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงแล้วคะตอนนี้เวลา 12:00
นเจียงกี่นาที
21 นาทีค่ะ
เจียงอี 11 นาทีต่อเป็นตอนกลางวันเป็น
รางวัลแล้วเย้
ครูฟ้าอยู่ที่บ้านใช่มั้ย
ผู้หญิงทุกเลยรู้ฟ้า
อยู่ที่บ้านใช่ไหม
กูฟ้าอยู่ที่บ้าน Only นะคะผู้หญิงฟ้าไม่
เคยอยู่ที่ไหนเลยฟ้าอยู่ที่บ้าน
รู้และก็รู้แล้วค่ะ
กูหญิงเขามาอธิบายอันนี้บ้านครูม้าเดี๋ยว
บ้านครูฟ้าเนี่ยมีต้นไม้ไหมโอ้
โห
ทำไมดูตั้งใจที่จะมีจริงหาย
มีต้นไม้ไหมคะ
มีต้นไม้ค่ะครูหญิงหนูที่บ้านครูฟ้าอย่าง
นี้ต้นไม้
ต้นไม้
ที่บ้านกูฟ้ามีต้นไม้หลายต้นเหรอคะเยอะ
เลยหามีมั่นไม้หลายต้นก็กิ่งนี้ออกไปก่อน
นะคะไม่ได้ไม่ได้เดี๋ยวเขาขึ้นไปอยู่ไม่
ได้นะอ่อที่บ้านกูมามีต้นไม้แล้วหวานตอน
นี้ฟ้ามีอันนี้ไหมมีตัวนี้ไหม
ปุ้ย
โดเรมอนไม่ใช่
มันหางเลย / กูมาที่บ้านครูฟ้ามีตัวนี้
เลยคะผู้ว่ารู้ไหมคะว่าตัวเขาเรียกว่า
อะไร
แมว
แมวกูไปแต่ไปได้ไหมอ่ะต้นไม้ต้นนี้มันบัง
แมวเห็นไหมขอ
เค้าออกแล้วค่ะแมวที่บ้านครูบามีแพรวไหม
คะมีแมวค่ะครูหญิงที่มันดูฟังข้ามีแมวกี่
ตัว
ที่บ้านครูฟ้ามีแมว 1 ตัว
1 ตัวว่ามีนิดหน่อยนะคะ
มีนิดหน่อยอ่ะ 1 ตัว
1 ตัว
แล้ว
ผู้หญิงถามทำไมคะผู้หญิงชอบแมวหรอคะก็
โอเคนะชอบมากกว่ามาไม่ฆ่าผู้หญิงจะถามครู
ฟ้าว่าว่าเนี่ยแมวสมัยแมวของครูฟ้า 1 ตัว
R อ่ะเปลี่ยนแมวครูฟ้าเนี่ยสวยมีอยู่ชาว
ไม่ซะ
ว่ามีรูปนะขอให้ดูรูปดีกว่า
แมวอยู่บนหลังคาเหรอผู้ฟ้าเดี๋ยวเขาให้
เธออีกมองไม่เห็นอันนี้ล่ะราคานักเรียน
แมวคู่ฟ้าอันนี้แมวอยู่บนหลังคาแมวครูฟ้า
น่าจะกินเก่งนะคะเนี่ยดูรูปร่าง
แมวอยู่บนหลังคายมั๊ยนักเรียนเมื่อว่านิ
หลังคานะคะมีลูกอื่นด้วยนะอ๋อนั้นคือ
หลังคานะคะที่นี่นะคะนักเรียนเนี่ยหลังคา
บ้านครูพุทธนอนบนหลังคา
แมวอยู่บนหลังคาได้ไหมครูฟ้าอะไรแล้วแมว
คุณครูฟ้าเนี่ยอยู่บนหลังคา
อยู่บนหลังคา
สีจะทำอะไรคะแล้วแมวเนี่ยมันก็
อ้าว
หนูไม่ได้นะครับแป๊บนึงนะคะนักเรียนขอเอา
หลังคาออกก่อน
แมวภูฟ้าเนี่ยมันอยู่บนหลังคาแล้วมันลงมา
ได้เหรอคะ
ได้สิคะผู้หญิงมันเป็นแมวแมวเนี่ยขึ้นที่
สูง Smart ที่สูงสุดโอเคขึ้นได้
ลงนาย 100 เมตร 100 เมตรมองไม่เห็นรู้
เห็นหรือเปล่าไม่เห็น
100 บาทผู้หญิงได้หรือยังคะ 100 เมตร
เนี่ยอยากอ้าว
โอเคไหม 100 เมตรใช่ไหมสูงแมวถ้ามันขึ้น
ที่สูงก็คือขึ้นไปบนหลังคามันก็ลงมาเอง
ได้น้อยแต่ทำไมเวลาแมวมันขึ้นไปอยู่บนต้น
ไม้
มันลงไม่ได้ล่ะ
เอ้า
มันกลัวทั้งสวย
[เพลง]
แต่ว่าหลังคาหลังคาก็สูงหลังคาเดี๋ยวมัน
จะมีเอ่อ
ที่คือโอ้โห
ได้เหรอคะหลังคามีที่ขึ้นแมวขึ้นโอเคแล้ว
ก็แมวลงใช่ไหม
ลงโอเคไม่กลัวแต่ต้นไม้เนี่ย
มันไม่มี
บันไดไม่มีเอาแมวน่ากลัวแมวกลัวใช่ไหม
แล้วถ้า 1 วันแมวครูฟ้าตัวนี้นะคะแมวครู
ฟ้าชื่อหมิวผู้หญิงรู้ด้วยนะแมว Google
อาจจะมีปันหามิ้วเนี่ยนะคะขึ้นไปบนต้นไม้
แล้วลงไม่ได้
ไม่ได้นะ
ครูฟ้าจะทำยังไงกูฟ้าจะไปช่วยแมวลงมาได้
ภูฟ้าอะดิมิฟ้านะฮะจะช่วยแมวลงมายังไงกู
มาไม่ต้องคิดครูหญิงมี Choice ให้อุ้ย
กูฟ้าเอา 1 ตัวออกไปได้ไหมผู้หญิงที่ชอบ
เหมือนมาเฟียอะ
อันนี้มันคืออ่าเอาบันไดออกไปด้วยค่ะ
เดี๋ยวเขาผู้หญิงลากแมวนะแมวเนี่ยขึ้นไป
บนดอกไม้ใช่ไหมคะ
คือแมวเนี่ยก็
จะแมวตัวใหญ่ขึ้นไม้
กูฟังดิขี้เกียจย่อแล้ว
แมวเนี่ยร้องไห้
แมวก็จะร้อง
เหมียวด้วยช่วยด้วยช่วยด้วย
ครูฟ้าจะช่วยแมวยังไงคุยยังมีตัวเลือกให้
นะคะ
1a แล้วกัน a ขอดูโพยก่อนนะคะ Gate อะไร
บ้าง a ถ้ามองไม่เห็นเลยผู้หญิงเอาหรอ
ปีกไม่ค่อยแน่ใจอ่าเดี๋ยวก็ผู้หญิงกั้น
ไว้ก่อนนะคะนักเรียนว่ามันได้ประมาณนี้
เป็นเขียนได้แค่นี้แล้วบอกตัวเองได้เลย
เอาแล้วผู้ช่วยค่ะนี่ชัดเจอแล้ว
rama9
นี้คือ a เอาเองไว้ที่นี่ a ก็คือครูฟ้า
เนี่ยแมวครูฟ้าชอบกินปลาใช่มั้ยใช่แมว
กูไฟล์ชอบกินปลาปลาแซลมอนปลาทูน่า
โอ้โห
นี่ลายภูฟ้าเนี่ยก็เอาปลาเนี่ยวางไว้ใต้
ต้นไม้แมวเนี่ยวันเห็นราวบอกอยากกินมันก็
จะลงมามันเหมือนไม่กลัวอันนี้ a นะหา
บีบี
ดีก็คือครูฟ้า
ที่กูฟ้าเหรอ
คุณผี
ฟ้าเนี่ยก็
เรียกแมวหมีน้องมิว meyou
เอ้าไม่รู้มิว
ก็คือบีครูฟ้าเนี่ยเรียกแมวไหมกูมาอาจจะ
เรียกเที่ยง
เหมียวๆมาพูดไม่
มีหัวใจแบ่งความว่าพี่มีไม่มีเออเนี่ยกู
ก็ mew  mew  mew ใช่ไหมเรียกแมวนะคะ
ca4 ก็คือฟ้า
ถ้าโตแล้วนะคะ
สีเหลืองครูป๋าสบายดีเป็นผม
ครูบาก็อาจต้องปีน
ปีนต้นไม้ขึ้นไปช่วยแมวนะคะนี่คือสิสีนะ
กูฟ้าก็ปีนต้นไม้ขึ้นไปช่วยแมว
1g  GE  GE ก็ครูฟ้าอีกแล้วนะคะน้องครู
บานะคะ
ครูฟ้าครูฟ้าก็มีของเล่นแต่ว่าอันนี้เป็น
ตุ๊กตาที่เป็นของเล่นแมวแมวชอบกัดใช่ไหม
กูป่าก็ของเล่นไปปะ
milk  milk เอาของเล่นไปเรียกแมว
ถ้าสมมุติว่าแมวครูฟ้าขึ้นไปบนต้นไม้แล้ว
ลงไม่ได้แมวก็ร้อง
ครูบาจะช่วยแมวยังไงคะบี
มีอีกหรอเอาไม่มีไม่มีหมดแล้วมีแค่แค่แค่
นี้พอแล้วก็คือเองอาเจ้เาลาวางไว้ซ้ายต้น
ไม้มีร้องเรียกแมวสีครูบาปีนปีนต้นไม้
ขึ้นไปช่วยแล้วก็ดีเอาของเล่นแมวมาเรียก
แมวสีฟ้าจะช่วยแมวของครูฟ้ายังไงครูฟ้าจะ
ตีรีบไปช่วยแมวค่ะ Oppo ๆ
ทำไมอ่ะทำไมกูฟ้าปีนขึ้นไปอ่ะเอ้าแมวกู
ฟ้าเนี่ยร้องไห้เห็นแหมท้องให้แปลว่าแมว
กลัว
เองถ้าถ้าเอาปลามาวางไว้แมวก็ไม่กินเพราะ
ว่ากลัวถ้ากูฟ้าเรียก
แมวก็ไม่มาเพราะว่ากลัว
5 กูฟ้าเอาของเล่นของน้องแมว
ของเล่นมาวางไว้แนวก็ไม่มาเพราะกลัวค่ะพา
ก็จะปีนขึ้นไปช่วยแมวค่ะเอาโห
[ปรบมือ]
[เพลง]
เขาสูงสูงอาจจะซัก 3 เมตร 3 เมตร
อุปกรณ์แมวอุ้มแมวแล้วก็พาก็
เรียกแม่นะแม่เอาโยนแมวไปกบอ๋อนึกว่าพี่
ฟ้าก็โอแมวภูฟ้าแป๊บนึงนะคะออกไปก่อน
หูฟ้านะอ่ากูฝาก็อุ้มแมว
ทุ่มแมวแมวแมวให้มันเล็กลงหน่อยนะคะ
เราก็ครูฟ้าใช่ไหมกูฟ้าเนี่ยก็อุ้มมือ
อุ้ม
แล้วก็นั่งอยู่ที่นี่แล้วก็แม่แม่
ช่วย
แม่เอา
ผ้าห่มหมอนเวลานอนให้มีผ่อน I  was มา
แล้วก็จะโยนไปเอา
หรือฟ้าสู่ฟาร์มถ้าคุณพ่อคุณแม่ใช่ไหมก็
ให้คุณแม่เอาบ่นมาวางที่นี่แล้วก็ไงผม
แล้วฟ้าก็โยนแมวลงมาโยนแมวลงมาใช่ค่ะแล้ว
ก็ฝาก็อยู่ข้างบนใช่ไม่ได้
กูก็จะลงให้
แม่ก็บอกฟ้านอนบนต้นไม้โอเคนะ
ไว้ได้เธอเธออะครัวเลือกซีสมัยปีนขึ้นไป
ช่วยแนวชายถ้าเป็นครูหญิงล่ะผู้หญิงจะ
เลือกอะไรผู้หญิงเลือดเอเอเอเอ
ทำไม
เอ้าครูหญิงเนี่ย
ปีนต้นไม้ไม่ได้
เฮ้ยนี่เนี่ย C แหละคุยต้องปีนต้นไม้ใส่
พิมพ์ต้องแบบกระทืบพฤขึ้นไปนะผู้หญิงอ่ะ
ปีนได้
ไม่ได้ไม่สบายสิไม่ได้กินไม่ได้อ้ะเอา
อาหารแมว
อาหารแมวมาแล้วก็เมี้ยวๆๆหอมนะหอมน้าแมว
จะได้รู้สึกอยากกินแต่งปลาทำแมวไม่ลงมา
ผู้หญิงก็จะเรียกแมว
aria แมวก็ไม่ลงมาคุยก็จะเอาของเล่น
เรียกแบบแอลแล้วถ้าของเล่นเรียกแมวแล้ว
แมวไม่ลงมา
คุยก็ต้องปีน
เฮ้ย
เอาครูฟ้าออกไปนะคะเก็บไว้แค่แมว
แต่ว่าผู้หญิงก็ไม่ตีนี่ไงภูฟ้าผู้หญิง
ต่อไปนี้ให้กูฟ้านะคะอ้าว
ผู้หญิงก็ไม่เป็นไงแล้วผู้หญิงทำอะไรนี่
ไงต้องออกรบๆหญิงก็เอาบันได
บันได
ไปเอาบันได
ผู้หญิงอะไรกันใดมีปันไดสมัยแล้วก็ครู
หญิงก็ขึ้นบันไดไป
อาจจะไม่ต้องขึ้นถึงบนต้นไม้ใช่ไหมคะอ่า
ปิดก็อาจจะขึ้นบันได
เขาแป๊บนึงนะฮะอันนี้กูหญิงใช่ไหมผู้หญิง
ก็อาจจะขึ้นบันไดไว้ 1  2  3  4  5 ก็แขน
ขึ้นไปคุยไปแขนยาวนะคะแล้วก็อุ้มแมวแล้ว
ก็ลงนะโอ้ย
ตัวเมียผู้หญิงก็จะตีมันใดช่วยแมวนะคะ
แล้วนักเรียน
นักเรียนจะทำยังไงถ้าเกิดแมวติดอยู่บนต้น
ไม้
นั้นเอ๊ะทำยังไงเนี่ยจะลึก
a
b หารแล้วอาหารแมว B เรียกแมวสมัยเรียบ
ซีขึ้นต้นไม้ไปช่วยแมวดีอะไรนะของเล่นของ
เล่นแมวนักเรียนจะช่วยแมวลงจากต้นไม้ยัง
ไงหรือว่านักเรียนแบบนั้นแล้วอ้า oku
หญิงมีไอเดียมีไอเดียอย่างอื่นอีกก็
คอมเพล็กซ์บอกได้นะที่ไม่ใช่ a ไม่ใช่บี
ไม่ใช่สิอิอิถ้ามีอย่างอื่นอะไรที่นัก
เรียนบ่ผู้อันนี้ช่วยแมวแบบนี้ดีกว่า
อาหารพานักเรียนนี้ก็คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้
รายเมียนนักเรียนจะช่วยแมวลงจากต้นไม้ยัง
ไงมีแต่ว่าวีดีโอนี้มึงเวลาแล้วนะคะครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยต้องไปช่วยแนวตอนนี้คุณฟ้าได้ยิน
เสียงแมวร้องเหมียวๆๆครูฟ้าต้องไปช่วยแมว
แล้วนะคะแล้วงั้นคนบ้างไปก่อนละกันวีดีโอ
หน้านะคะสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ